gestalten wie aus einem albtraum einmal
im jahr werden sie losgelassen
[Musik]
im idyllischen örtchen heldra im norden
des bundeslandes hessen ein dorf mit
gerade mal 500 einwohnern aber mit einer
großen tradition den strohbären und ich
werde einer von ihnen sein
meine herausforderung heute ich lass
mich nicht nur um den finger sondern
ganz einwickeln und zwar mit stroh 40
kilo davon solch tragen
in dieser scheune kann ich mir schon mal
anschauen was mich nachher erwartet
allerdings bin ich heute als letzter an
der reihe
zeit für eine kleine recherche zur
geschichte des sturen am dorfmuseum
hallo hallo ich würde gern mal ein
bisschen mehr über den ursprung des
strohbären erfahren wie fingen das dann
alles an diese tradition das licht im
dunkeln also wir kennen den strombedarf
seit unserer frühesten jugend sondern
sind genau seit frühster jugend also da
ist kein datum fest gehalten
das hat bisher bedeutet immer noch das
winter austreiben
zurück zur scheune die menge des strohs
das vom winter übrigblieb bestimmt wie
viele strohbären mitlaufen können in
diesem jahr reicht es für 6 das brechen
des strohs an den gelenken gehört dazu
sonst könnten die bären sich gar nicht
bewegen
wer fertig ist muss vor der scheune
warten dass sich hier mitmachen darf ist
eine ausnahme ob es auch eine gute idee
ist da bin ich mir nicht mehr so sicher
[Musik]
jetzt werde ich ins stroh gewickelt
übrigens von echten profis keiner hier
macht das zum ersten mal bis zu zwei
stunden kann es dauern bis das ganze
stroh da sitzt wo es hingehört die
meisten der wickler waren selbst schon
mal ein strohbär mitleid haben sie
jedoch nicht gezogen und zerren
erbarmungslos an mir am oberschenkel
also hinten haben wir stehen für die
weit vom archiv da geht noch ein
bisschen
wickel prozess ist für denjenigen der
drin steckt gar nicht so ungefährlich
arme und beine können einschlafen wenn
es fest gewickelt wurde und nicht wenige
sind auch schon mal in ohnmacht gefallen
auch deshalb wird das stroh an den
gelenken gebrochen und so zwingt mich
diese uralte tradition in die knie
ich solle mehr bewegungsfreiheit
gewinnen verlieren aber dabei fast die
balance mein erster gang ein taxi für
die bären gibt es nicht die richtige
strohballen werden sie mit dem traktor
richtung startpunkt gekehrt selten habe
ich mich so ausgeliefert gefühlt
[Musik]
aber es gibt licht am horizont jemand
wird sich in den nächsten stunden um
mich kümmern muss ich auch ich habe
keine andere wahl denn auch das gehört
zur tradition jedermann im stroh bekommt
eine bären führerin die ihn an einer
kette durchs dorf leitet im stroh
stecken ohne ausnahme nur junge männer
keiner älter als ende 20 denn die halten
die strapazen am besten aus jeder
schleppt jetzt circa 40 kilo mit sich
herum und strohbären bleibt tatsächlich
nichts erspart
ich habe gerade erst meine verkleidung
laufen gelernt da soll ich tanzen in
grauer vorzeit mal die gelegenheit für
die dorfjugend sich näherzukommen mit
sicherheitsabstand aus stroh
nach zwei sehr langen stunden gibt es
den endspurt im wahrsten sinne des
wortes alle strohbären rennen los ich
kann es kaum noch aushalten und den
anderen geht es nicht anders die
strohbären enden als wilder haufen aber
endlich werden wir befreit und aus dem
stroh geschnitten was für eine tortur
stroh erste sitzen noch über
[Applaus]
dass sich die strapazen lohnen auch das
spüre ich jetzt ganz hautnah der tagen
endet mit einem großen feuer all das
stroh das stundenlang gewickelt und von
uns getragen wurde geht in wenigen
minuten in rauch auf so waren waren wir
ungefähr im kostüm auch selbst aber was
ich gelernt habe es war eine wirklich
schöner tag eine echt schöne tradition
die das ganze dorf die ganze gemeinde
zusammen gebracht hat und für einen tag
war ich auch teilt und wer genau hier
einer der anstrengendsten tage meines
reporter lebens geht zu ende
in die haut der strohbären werde ich
mich wohl nicht noch einmal wickeln
lassen